pour moi la vie est sacrée pour moi
l'humain est sacrée et qui sommes-nous
pour ôter et penser ôté la vie à
quelqu'un ça c'est ma conviction
profonde est ma conviction personnelle
jusqu'au jour où j'ai fait mon premier
livre l'affairé flactif un homme qui a
assassiné qui a été assassinée par son
voisin jaloux lui sa femme et ses trois
enfants de 6 à 10 dans son chalet dans
des conditions absolument terrible
atroce j'ai fait deux ans dans question
ce livre est qu'ils ont on en a fait un
film et c'est une affaire terrible est
cet homme
l'assassin va sortir d'emploi être à oui
il va sortire dont peut-être de trois
ans maximum 500 ha parce que ce rappel
était en 2013 c'est une histoire de
jalousie
il avait deux chalets voilà qui gagne
très bien sa vie
exactement exactement les flactif et il
avait assassiné toute la famille là et
même si les mêmes maps n'était même
apparue à la télévision pour voilà en
tant que témoin pour accuser la victime
d'être coupable exactement est classé
que dans notre société d'aujourd'hui est
donc il va sortir vos trois ans grâce
essentiellement de trois ans j'ai vu la
souffrance de la famille j'ai vécu avec
la famille ce qui reste de la famille et
je me suis demandé mais pourquoi la
prison à vie n'existe pas en france
pourquoi la prison à perpétuité n'existe
pas en france et moi je me suis dit que
jose ne pas être hypocrite et dire oui
pourquoi parce que la peine de mort en
tant qu'arme qu'en tant que bombes
nucléaires judiciaire en tant qu'arme de
dissuation massive
oui je pense qu' il serait intéressant
de la barre attention techniquement
c'est impossible de la voir en france 1
c'est pas on peut pas revenir en arrière
mais c'est impossible on revient en
arrière là dessus il est possible qu'on
revienne en arrière ça serait vraiment
trop compliqué je le donnais mon avis
impossible qu'on revienne là-dessus il
faudrait sortir de l'europe etc
c'est hyper compliqué et c'est jean mené
à nous dira ce qu'il en pense d'eux sans
doute à louis christ mais je veux dire
que si aujourd'hui le président
d'assises ou bien un juré ne jamais
donner à un condamné
justement à la peine
si mal qui est justement la prison à
perpétuité
et si on a cette arme de dissuasion
massive qui comme une bombe nucléaire
qu'on n'utilise pas mais on sait qu'on a
qu'on l'a ça permettrait d'avoir la
prison à perpétuité
ça c'est mon élan